now we were supposed to have the brexit
Party leader at Nigel Farraj on the
program today we're just talking about
him earlier in that interview but
unfortunately he pulled out and couldn't
make it hopefully he will be on the show
in the next few weeks though for now
they were joined by the SPS Westminster
leader in Blackford he was in
Westminster thank you very much for
being on the program today mr. Blackford
well we're gearing up for an election
aren't we what would be a good night for
the SNP well a good night for the SNP is
sending a very strong message from
Scotland to Westminster that we have to
have a see in our future we're going
into this election defending 35 seats in
Scotland out of 59 and we want to
improve upon that we're taking the
challenge of winning gold seats to all
our opponents the Conservative Labor and
Liberal Democrat MPs you know there was
a poll last week that showed that the
SNP are still by far and away the
leading party in Scotland a gap of 20
points plus against the Conservatives in
second place and is I would say pretty
remarkable that given we've been in
government since 2007 in Scotland that
we're still leading the way and seemed
to have the faith in the trust of a
large number of Scottish people were
very grateful about that but this is a
crucial time it is about demonstrating
that we're not going to hello Boris
Johnson to take us out of the European
Union against our will and there's an
opportunity for people in Scotland to
vote for the SNP a vote for a
confirmation that we want to have that
independence referendum that we need to
have that route to secure in our own
future as an independent country in the
European Union well let's talk about and
the drive that the SNP had to try and
get that second independence referendum
there is of course and the idea that
there could be a hung parliament it
could be deals been negotiated Jeremy
Corbyn is said he wouldn't grant a
second independence referendum in the
early years
if a Labour administration is that good
enough for you or doesn't need to be
next year well I think what everyone has
to recognize whether it's Boris Johnson
whether it's Jeremy Corbyn is that when
the SNP went to the polls in 2016 in
Scotland for the Scottish election we
did that on a manifesto commitment that
if there was a change in circumstances
then we'd reserve the right to have a
referendum we won that election with the
government in Scotland and any Prime
Minister should respect democracy it
should be the people of Scotland it
should be the Scottish Parliament that
decides when
however having a referendum and will not
be stopped by Boris Johnson Jeremy
Corbyn or anyone else there is a real
risk that we faced with what the
government is seeking to do to take us
out to the European Union we know that
we'll be in transition till the end of
2020 we need to make sure that we can
protect our economy that we can protect
jobs that we can protect the supply of
medicines and foods from an audio brexit
for example so we need to have that
referendum so we can secure that place
in Europe for us that is legislation
which is currently going through the
Scottish Parliament a referendum bill it
completed its first stage this week
Westminster has to recognize as our
right to choose and nobody but nobody
should stand in the way of the Scottish
people expressing their desire to have a
referendum on independence you I
mentioned No Deal in that answer and of
course the SNP is consistently voted on
to try and stop a No Deal brexit from
happening so my question to you is if
you do get the second independence
referendum that you want and Scotland
votes to leave would you be happy to
just stay in the UK indefinitely if the
UK Parliament refused to grant New Deal
at the end of the day the UK Parliament
can't refuse to grant a deal to us
because the simple fact is that we won
the election in 2016 we have that
manifest of commitment we won the
election to Westminster and 20 it could
be a deal is not agreed in the same way
that a deal and you know what has been
agreed with the EU but it's been
consistently blocked by the UK
Parliament you could absolutely see that
situation happening well you're talking
about I'm not quite sure what you're
saying you're talking about Westminster
refusing to give us a referendum you're
talking about a deal on Europe I'm
talking about a deal well as you're
talking about a deal on Europe at the
end of the day we've done an economic
impact assessment published by the
Scottish Government just a few weeks ago
that shows that one Boris Johnson's deal
that the economy in Scotland would be 6%
weaker than what it would be by staying
in the European Union we're never going
to vote for anything and support
anything there's going to cost jobs of
people in Scott but why would we do that
it's inconceivable that we would do so
we want to stay in the European Union
we've said repeatedly that we'll do what
we can to make sure that all of the UK
stays in the European Union that's in
all our best interest but ultimately we
have got that right to choose our own
future in Scotland and choose to become
an independent nation in Europe because
it's about what we would then do with
that
it's about the desire that we have the
burning desire to grow our economy to
deliver fairness to take her climate
change responsibility seriously but of
course who else were still in the United
Kingdom we will work with others to stop
wrecks it because for us this campaign
as much as anything else is about
stopping brexit something which is going
to harm the economy but also reduce
rights for people if you think about it
today we as EU citizens have the rights
to live and work to get an education and
28 EU Member States that's going to be
taken away from us and I really grieve
at the what we're doing what we're doing
to our young people that are going to
suffer so much of Boris Johnson and his
brakes at fanboys and number 10 get
their way and I know that of course you
are always keen to talk about Scottish
independence we talk a lot about brexit
in these interviews but I'm just
interested to know on some of your other
priorities what would be red lines if
there is a hung parliament if you're
going into some of these negotiations
with perhaps the Labour Party in order
to get a Jeremy Corbyn into number 10
after the election in 2015 Nicola
Sturgeon said that scrapping trident
would be a red line in any negotiations
with the ends SNP without also apply
this time round well we will come up
with a wish list of things that we want
to see but I think it's fair to say
there are a number of things which at
the top of our list austerity is a issue
because we've been pretty consistent
down through the decades that we don't
wish to see nuclear weapons in our soil
we want to make sure of course that we
take our responsibilities for defence
seriously and I think it's important to
say that in today of all days remember
but Remembrance Sunday to look forward
to but we don't believe that we should
be investing in those weapons of mass
destruction but there are a number of
things that we want to see Sophie we
want to see the end of austerity and if
I look at the Scottish Government's
block grant from Westminster in real
terms has been cut by 5% by the Tories
over the course of the last 10 years
really impacting our public services is
the poorest in society that are paying
the price for Tory austerity and we want
to see an end to that but we also have
to quicken our action on climate change
given that we are looking at an election
than were electing a government in the
UK for the next five years we need to
make sure that we recognize that there
is a climate emergency and we have to
speed me back to trident and
can you see and the SMP propping up a
government in Westminster who were
committed to the renewal of Trident well
we would simply say that these weapons
are not fit for purpose and the simple
fact of the matter is I'm not sure that
we're taking our responsibilities for
conventional defense as seriously as we
should be doing
there's a shortage of active warships in
the UK for the moment as an example and
I think to waste up to 200 billion
pounds on these weapons of mass
destruction that can never be used as a
fallacy what we need to do is to make
sure that we take our responsibilities
seriously that we take account of the
security challenges that we face here
and abroad that's what we should be
doing these nuclear weapons are not the
answer for the needs of defence and
security of the United Kingdom